you see that a lot of artists are going
back they're performing live and i
understand what listen this is how
artists make their living particularly
in your business in the music business
but you have said listen i'm not
throwing any live shows it ain't
happening there's a
people are walking around without masks
we got a pandemic going
i don't like what's going on are you
still holding true to that
absolutely
good for you people are not uh they're
just not being
uh realistic and they're not being
scientific if we followed the rules of
science and everybody got vaccinated
we'd have a lot better chance what do
you say to these people in your personal
life who won't get vaccinated i've given
up i i'm like you got to be [ __ ]
kidding me uh well i say are you
vaccinated and if they say no i say well
i'll see you that's right that's why
everybody uh everybody in the band and
everybody in the crew and everybody
there that was at the barn they were all
vaccinated
uh these things make me sound like an
angry person
but really i'm just i'm actually very
happy to be here on the planet to see
this
and to to bear witness to what's going
on i'm not happy about what's happening
but i am definitely very happy and
thankful that i was born at this time
that i get to see this this is an
amazing moment in the human history
we are we're this is there's never been
anything quite like this
and and it's such a
we ought to be thankful that we have a
chance to maybe show how to beat this
we might be able to beat this we can
still beat it there's no reason why we
can't i mean if we came together we
could take care of this
and uh and and i have confidence that we
can i'm just saying i'm not going to be
there on tv somebody's going to see me
playing on tv a bunch of people in the
crowd all standing there with no masks
on hey everything's cool neil's doing it
no that's not that's not it i don't care
if i'm the only one who doesn't do it
thank you for saying that i admire that
it's in your bones to perform you love
to perform and i know you would love it
i don't think and i yes and i don't
think you say that easily that you're
going to stop touring until this thing
but i agree with you it's too confusing
a message you know you got the
pendulum's got to swing a long way
before a big change happens and then it
starts coming back because that's that's
history that's the way it is so i feel
good i think we're going to make it
and i think we're going to turn this
around we've got a lot of small
smart people in the world with a lot of
great ideas
and uh and the more love there is in the
world the more we're going to hear those
ideas and we're going to make this
happen
i'm not backing off i'm not backing off
for a minute i'm not giving up
and the fact that i'm not going on the
road doesn't mean that i don't care